Perfection it always feels maddeningly
Out Of Reach but I think there are ways
to get closer to it and the flow Arts
can help Drex here from drexfactor POI I
make videos about POI spinning and flow
Arts to benefit your body and brain and
today I'm inspired to talk about
perfection expertise and how we can
attain both before we dive in I want to
give a quick shout out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyro Terra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that I've got
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to non-business
friends of the channel Johnny Howard
Lane machinsky and Becca becklinen thank
you all so very much for your support
from my work and my mission recently I
started following British YouTuber Mary
spender and she's really been on a hot
streak covering great topics and
terrific depth if you haven't already
you should really go check her out one
of her recent videos was on the topic of
perfection
Perfection and in the course of it she
basically walked through the greatest
hits of things that inspired my own
Journey at the beginning of the 2010s
the Cliff's Notes here are that Mary
like me has long been obsessed with the
idea of gaining expertise in his skill
and more specifically in perfecting it
watching her talk about her journey
inspired me to look back at my own
journey and why the goal of achieving
Perfection was one that I was and
continue to be so taken with and more
specifically why I think things like
music and especially the flow Arts are
well suited to learning the techniques
for perfecting a skill so let's start
off by talking about my own Journey
first POI spinning is actually the third
creative career that I've embarked on in
my life and the others followed a
remarkably specific trajectory I would
find something creative that would
inspire me and I would dive into
learning more about it I'd read books
subscribe to magazines back when that
was a thing and practice practice
practice endless hours and I would
usually see an initial burst of success
my skills would surpass many of those
around me and I'd get to feeling like I
was good at this thing and I had found
my passion in life I thought that the
Improvement in skill was directly
commensurate with how good of a fit this
thing was for me as a person and I'd
dive into it with body mind and soul and
then
I'd hit a plateau maybe it would happen
slowly maybe it would hit me like a ton
of bricks but either way I'd find myself
in a position where despite practicing
the same number of hours I wasn't
actually getting any better sometimes my
peers would begin to overtake me and
skill and recognition sometimes I just
wasn't getting the same charge out of it
that I once did and all that really
discouraged me sound familiar it
wouldn't shock me a lot of us go through
this process and find ourselves
frustrated again and again with the
results many of us then decide that this
wasn't actually our thing after all and
move on to the next skill only to have
the pattern repeat again and again what
broke the cycle for me was reading a
book called Mastery by George Leonard
wherein he not only outlined the exact
cycle I'd been going through but also
offered up a solution commit to the
thing and learn to love the plateau
because you're going to wind up spending
a whole lot of time on it it just so
happened that I'd started spinning poi
right about the time that I read his
book and it became a foundational work
for me and understanding my potential
with the art and where I could go with
it if I applied myself in the right way
as time went on I dove deeper into the
literature around how people achieve
expertise in various fields and came
across the research of Anders Erickson
which has since and somewhat
inaccurately been popularized as the Ten
Thousand hour rule the basic idea is
this when you take a cohort of people
held up by their peers as having
achieved expertise in a given skill you
find that the average amount of practice
that it took them to achieve that feat
is around 10 000 hours or roughly 10
years of regular part-time practice but
I also ran across a lot of research not
just on how much but also what kind of
practice leads to those achievements
this is one of the problems with how
Erickson's research was simplified and
popularized because it's not simply that
you need to do the same thing for ten
thousand hours and poof expertise
achieved it's that you have to engage in
what's called deliberate practice in
order to get there and the trick here is
that deliberate practice is hard so what
makes practice deliberate Erickson's
research defines deliberate practice as
having the following three qualities
number one it's designed specifically to
improve performance doing this involves
identifying the skills you currently
have and in what way those skills are
currently lacking and can be improved
one example from my own work I've
noticed the Gunslingers I do with my
left hand have less stable planes than
those that I perform with my right so I
begin every practice session doing a
series of drills with only my left hand
to balance the two out number two you
receive immediate feedback on the
success of your results if there's a
long lag between the practice you're
doing and the outcome of said practice
it can make it difficult to know what
you still have to improve on this is
really easy to see it work with POI
because if you're unsuccessful in your
attempt at a given trick technique or
move it's pretty likely you're gonna hit
yourself and that makes for some very
important if not always Pleasant
feedback and finally the skill you're
practicing needs to be able to be heated
a lot repetition builds familiarity a
lot of people who've taken workshops or
classes from me will know that I'm a
stickler for reps I don't just want you
to get the trick I want to know that you
can do 10 reps of it at the drop of a
hat that repetition is what gives you
the muscle memory necessary to pull off
that trick whenever you want to so the
formula for achieving expertise is
actually pretty simple design your
practice around things you want to
improve on make sure you get immediate
feedback on the efficacy of that
practice and repeat it copiously and
frequently repeat this process regularly
for roughly a decade and voila expertise
as some of you may be picking up each of
these characteristics is something that
the flow Arts are actually pretty good
at providing not only does spinning
props give you access to instant
feedback but doing it repetitively is
kind of baked into the sauce once you
get a new trick who doesn't like to bust
out a bunch of reps of it doing so used
to be an entire genre of video on the
internet the one tricky part is
designing your practice around and
Improvement many of us do this in a
fairly undirected fashion While others
will say pick a harder trick they'd like
to learn and spend a bunch of time
drilling the skills necessary to get
that trick down both are totally valid
but if you'd like some outside help
guiding your practice to make it more
deliberate I would just like to point
out that I'm currently hosting live
stream classes every week where I'm
teaching basic POI techniques with an
eye towards learning how to dance and
express yourself with POI from the very
beginning if that sounds up your alley
you can sign up over at crowdcast.io
drexfactor POI now learning about
achieving expertise and how to get there
wasn't really the end of the road for me
nor was it for Mary either we both
became really inspired by stories of
people who'd applied these Concepts
whether they were aware of it or not
into their work Mary cites Giro Ono a
sushi chef who was profiled in the 2011
documentary Giro Dreams of Sushi as an
example of this ethos in effect and I
have to say I also watched this
documentary years ago and absolutely
loved it seeing the way that Jiro
approaches his craft and his obsession
with continuing to improve even in his
elderly years was hugely inspiring for
me one of my favorite reviews of the
movie cites the frequently cited three
Michelin stars jiro's restaurant was
awarded and includes this pretty Choice
quote as he serves a perfect piece of
sushi he observes it being eaten he
knows his staff has recently started
massaging an octopus for 45 minutes and
not half an hour
does he search a customer's eyes for a
signal that this change has been an
improvement
half an hour of massage was good enough
to win three Michelin stars you realize
the tragedy of Giro Ono's life is that
there are not and will never be four
stars
[Music]
I love this
said perfectionism is also something
that can be framed along a spectrum
depending upon who is doing the framing
it can be seen as compulsive or
pathological on one extreme or inspiring
and motivating at another extreme I'm
currently reading brene Brown's atlas of
the heart and she has this to say about
perfectionism perfectionism kills
curiosity by telling us we have to know
everything or we risk looking less than
perfectionism tells us that our mistakes
and failures are personal defects so we
either avoid trying new things or we
barely recover every time we inevitably
fall short now I do think that brown is
identifying something real and important
in this I've seen perfectionism at its
worst put people in a place where they
are so afraid of negative judgments that
they avoid creating anything for fear of
the reception to it but I don't think
that brown is talking about
perfectionism in the same sense that
either Mary spender or IR sure I feel
some degree of Shame over releasing
something that I've created that I know
I could have done better on but that
doesn't stop me from creating those
things and it doesn't stop me from
striving to get better at its best
making the commitment to engage in the
tools of deliberate practice and by
extension searching for Perfection is an
act of humility it is looking at oneself
seeing and accepting the ways in which
one can improve and looking at that not
as a failure of character but as a
temporary state that we ourselves have
the ability to change and to Circle back
around I think flow Arts is great at
this when we look at a trick that we
want to learn but can't do just yet I
don't think that we consider ourselves
less than for not knowing how to do it
we need to learn the techniques to get
it down we don't come out of the womb
spinning poi so how can we judge
ourselves for not knowing how to do it
automatically between basically being an
ideal laboratory for learning the
techniques associated with deliberate
practice and being a great space for
identifying ways in which we can improve
at a skill without falling into
self-critical judgment I think flow
reports is somewhat unique in that it
gives us a window into all of these
facets of achieving expertise I
certainly have taken the lessons learned
from the silly hobby of spinning props
and applied them to other aspects of my
life to become better at creating
content marketing myself and even
improving my friendships and
relationships
anything you want to improve at you can
work on and flow Arts are an excellent
way to learn those skills and take them
forward into other parts of your life
sometimes I think it's easier to learn
critical skills in an environment that
feels like it's not earth-shatteringly
important before applying said skills in
something that feels like it is flow
Arts are a great sandbox for this
particular aspect of improving ourselves
and our skills over time but what has
your experience been do you find
perfectionism and working to achieve
expertise intimidating or even
destructive
did the flow Arts teach you techniques
for self-improvement that have had
broader impacts on your life leave me a
comment and let me know if you're
interested in any of the things that I
talked about in this video I'll leave
links to where you can check out my
sources and learn more in the
description and hey if you made it this
far then I'm hoping you learned
something or were at least entertained
and I'd love to ask that you helped me
out then by leaving a like comment
subscribe and share the video if you can
that helps more people find this content
and that helps me keep on creating it
this video would not be possible if not
for the wonderful support of all of
these amazing people right here these
are my flow patrons over on patreon and
they along with the people listed down
in the description help to make this
video and all the videos on my channel
possible thank you one and all for your
support do you like my videos do you
like my flow sessions Vlogs reviews
Combos and more I'm on a mission to
bring POI spinning and flow Arts to The
Wider world and help people connect with
their brains and their bodies so help me
do it head on over to patreon.com
drexfactor POI and sign up you can do
that at the link in the description or
the card that just popped up if you're
watching on YouTube there you can get
access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and help me along in my mission
do check that out please and thank you
if you're interested in checking out
more of my content around flow Arts
culture and the benefits of it I will
leave a link to a playlist down in the
description as well as up on screen the
YouTube algorithm also thinks based upon
your past viewing habits that you'll
like this other video up top too so
maybe give that a look yeah thank you so
much for watching and I hope you have an
awesome day make sure to get out to flow
and I will see you with a new video on
Wednesday
peace